if you control the money you control the
world and so when you have something
like a central bank digital currency you
can just program it in order to promote
different political or woke ideologies
whatever it is so the world economic
forum for example we're talking about
implementing a carbon allowance which
basically means each individual will be
given a certain amount of carbon they
are allowed to emit how do they do this
well you program the money so say for
example you bought a lot of meat one
week you could actually reach short
carbon allowance and so when you go to
fill up your car go see family or
whatever it is your money could get
declined and so now what they've done is
those unelected Elites are the world
economic Forum have implemented their
political ideology through a central
bank digital currency it's the most
effective way to implement these
tyrannical woke ideologies